[Music]
Germany is that country that always
seems to be at the top of the rankings
in terms of productivity quality of life
and human development this major
economic power is seen by many
politicians analysts and Experts of all
kinds as a true role model yet visual
politic community in recent times other
types of news stories have been making
more and more headlines we are referring
specifically to things like these Berlin
post-pandemic crime rates surges in the
German Capital German police call for
knife free zones in cities too much
crime too few Personnel breman's police
chief sounds the alarm the increase in
burglaries and vehicle thefts is
particularly shocking you see as
unbelievable as it may seem to us the
truth is that Germany is currently
experiencing a very strong upturn in its
crime and violent crime figures never
mind that such problems are often
associated with high poverty rates high
levels of marginalization or lack of law
enforcement Germany one of the richest
and most developed countries in the
world has none of these problems and yet
crime figures are suddenly skyrocketing
according to official data from the
police themselves the country is facing
an incipient wave of robberies murders
sex crimes and human trafficking in this
respect Germany is experiencing its
worst period of at least the last
[Music]
decade now you may be asking yourself a
question but Josh Germany really I had
heard it was precisely the opposite
situation in Mighty Germany well guess
what it's no wonder not so long ago the
situation was very different in fact as
recent as 2019 the situation was exactly
the opposite at that time truth be told
not so long ago Germany was boasting
Germany records lowest crime rate since
1992 Germany's crime rate Falls to
lowest level in decades what the hell is
going on with with crime in Germany what
on Earth could explain this wave of
violence and insecurity well these are
the questions that we've been asking at
visual politic questions that we're
going to answer in this video fire up
your engines and let's get
[Applause]
[Music]
started if we're talking about history I
think it is clear that Germany is a
country that has a bit of everything in
the last century alone we can list two
World Wars the most intense territorial
dispute of the Cold War a unification of
east and west the creation of the
European Union and much more well in
terms of security Germany has gone
through difficult times particularly in
the 1990s the reunification of the
Federal Republic of Germany with a
German Democratic Republic the satellite
state of the Soviet Union brought with
it many problems reunification meant
that communist Germany had to adapt to a
new market economy overnight this meant
that many state-owned companies had to
close unemployment soared which
temporarily aggravated the fact that
poverty levels were already much higher
than in the west to make matters worse
the East German police specialized in
social control censorship and political
repression so it had to be remodeled
from top to bottom not only
operationally but also culturally the
result well as you can imagine a
landscape particularly prone to the
proliferation of crime of course the
economic situation did improve following
reunification both due to the opening up
of the economy and because of the
enormous amount of Aid the federal
government showered on Eastern Germany
and that Improvement then translated
into a reduction in crime rates security
improved in the 1990s East Germany was
considered the stronghold of crime in
Germany in the mid 1990s crime in the
East was 20% higher than in the west
then crime in the East gradually
declined and was lower than in the West
for the first time in 2009 as a result
Germany improved its safety level to
almost the European average better than
countries like France and worse than
others like Poland let's to say that the
upturn in the crime rate was transitory
it was a direct effect of the absorption
of the Eastern block however the spiking
crime that is now occurring is a
completely different situation with
reunification over what on Earth is
causing this loss of security why is
crime On The Rise the Germans themselves
have been taken by surprise even so
there are already sever answers on the
table do you want to know what they are
well let's get into
it clarifying the
numbers but before we get into the
nitty-gritty there are a few things to
keep in mind first of all we have
cheated a little yes crime in Germany
has risen but we are still talking about
a European country Berlin's reported
figures for robberies and homicides are
extremely low compared to the rest of
the world we are still still talking
about a reasonably safe country overall
nowhere near the data coming from the
United States Latin America or even
Canada for example Germany reports a
homicide rate of 0.76 persons per
100,000 inhabitants and that is nothing
this is a dream figure for other
countries such as the USA which reports
a level of 6.81 homicides per 100,000
inhabitants almost 10 times higher and
let's not even talk about Latin America
whose figure for 2021 was
19.9 and although in other areas of
crime the differences are smaller the
fact is that Germany is still a European
country in other words in terms of crime
it is light years ahead of the American
countries could that change we shall
see secondly we have to be clear about
the effect of the pandemic its economic
impact caused a general upturn in crime
worldwide you know how it goes higher
unemployment less income more
uncertainty Europe and Germany were no
exception if we compare the homicide
rate between 2019 and 2020 Germany
ranked sixth in the region where these
crimes increased the most it is enough
to look at the ranking to see that the
Germans had an evolution close to that
of Malta Cyprus or Portugal countries
with which berin is not usually compared
now the problem is not that homicide
skyrocketed during the pandemic but that
in the Years following this trend was
not reversed and here comes the surprise
while countries such as Estonia and
Lithuania managed to reverse increases
in crime the drop in crime in Germany in
2021 was not enough to completely
reverse the escalation reported during
the pandemic and then in 2022 and 2023
the data worsened and this is precisely
the concern of the German authorities
unlike its neighbors crime in the
country is getting worse year after year
with no clear economic cause to support
this
situation
why so much alarmism if the data seems
reasonably good well as we say it has to
do above all with the evolution with the
evolution and with the fact that in the
German case homicides are not exactly
the crimes that have grown the most in
recent years take a look for example in
the case of human trafficking as you can
see the average for the 2020 to 2022
period is 55% higher than that reported
for the 2013 to 2015 period another
similar issue is sex crimes up until
2016 they numbered about 7,000 per year
but in 2018 these bordered on
11,200 and then in 2022 they reached
their historical Peak with
11,896 in other words the number of sex
crimes increased by 70% in just 5 years
then other crimes such as robberies both
common and aggravated by the use of
violence have rebounded sharply after 5
years of decline they did so
particularly after the lifting of Health
restrictions okay here's the situation
having clarified these numbers let's get
back to the key question what on Earth
is causing the spike in crime well watch
out because here comes the most
interesting part of
all big fish tank big
fishes dear visual politic Community the
size of your success will match the size
of your effort this phrase generally
attributed to the Venezuelan General
Francisco de Miranda seems to be the
inspiration for the hundreds of criminal
organizations operating in Germany a
country whose institutions are among the
strongest in the world well in recent
years the German Federal criminal
investigation office has taken a special
interest in organized crime when we talk
about organized crime we are referring
to criminal organizations that have a
strong operational capacity in Europe
and that in addition to kidnapping
robbery extortion and murder are also
involved in financial crime large- scale
fraud and political or cultural
intimidation these are all activities
that have increased in recent years in
other words we are not talking about
mere Petty thieves or swindlers but real
crime organizations but what is the
origin of these criminal groups what do
they do do they come from Germany or do
they come from neighboring countries
well the first thing that we have to
take into account is that according to
reports from the German authorities
themselves many of these groups are
involved in what is known as Clan crime
take a look at this in this context Clan
membership is a unifying component which
facilitates the commission of crimes or
obstructs the solving of crimes while
one's own standards and values can be
given priority over the German legal
system specifically according to the
German authorities four major groups
stand out first of all we have the big
local talent The Outlaw motorcycle gangs
there are around 680 such associations
in Germany with a total of 7,800 members
in this segment groups such as MC BMC
gamium MC GMC and Hell's Angels MC HC
which have been banned from several
European nations stand out these
entities are mainly engaged in micro
crimes of drug distribution intimidation
and assaults then there is what could be
considered an old cliche but is
nonetheless a stark reality we are
referring to Italian organized crime the
notorious Mafia according to official
reports organized crime in Germany
linked to the mafia increased by 12.5%
in 2022 in this case they are mainly
engaged in extortion and Drug
distribution crime linked to Russian and
Eurasian organizations makes an
appearance in third place these entities
would be led and managed from countries
within the former Soviet orbit and
finally we have the Syrian and Lebanese
Clans whose presence has increased in
recent years and who play a key role in
drug trafficking and money
laundering as an overview you can see in
this chart what the major criminal
activities are that all these groups and
others commit in the country take a
look the form of violence used varies
greatly but it illustrates the general
violence and threat potential of OC
groups it ranges from verbal threats
hostage taking rape and bodily injury
offenses to attempted homicide it is
directed against members of both their
own group and those of rival OC groups
or against persons outside the group for
example example family members residing
in Germany or abroad okay and this is
where we come to the thorniest issue of
all immigration as you probably know
Germany has been one of the great
supporters of welcoming refugees in
Europe a position that has cost them
tough confrontations with countries like
Poland Hungary and even Denmark so many
of you are probably connecting the dots
immigration refugees and crime right
well wait a minute because in this case
the data does not seem to go that way on
the whole the upturn in violence in
Germany seems to be linked above all to
criminal groups and guess what of the
7,200 people arrested in 2022 on
suspicion of involvement in criminal
organizations just 750 were immigrants
that's 1 in 10 a percentage far below
the proportion of immigration itself in
Germany let's see it is clear that the
arrival of millions of people of low
income and from countries with very
different cultures has influenced the
commission of crimes however the big upt
the one promoted by criminal groups is
fundamentally led by German or by people
who arrived in the country a long long
time ago and that is not all another
important feature is that all these
organizations seem to believe in the
European project because the truth is
that they have woven their criminal
networks throughout the length and
breadth of the old continent and so
criminal organizations in Germany appear
to have a close relationship with their
counterparts in Holland and Spain
countries that have a high flow of
Maritime trade which is of course
directly linked to drug trafficking for
their part relations with groups in
turkey and Switzerland have to do with
human trafficking and financial crime in
this regard the Netherlands is one of
the cases that most worries the German
authorities why because they see the
Amsterdam Brussels axis as a macro
Gateway for drug trafficking and strong
pressures on the judicial system and of
course they are afraid that this
situation will spread to Germany
itself
at this point it is clear that the crime
problems facing Germany are quite unique
they have less to do with economic
marginality poverty or institutional
weakness which are the typical
ingredients and more to do with the fact
that the tonic nation is becoming the
operational base for a number of
European crime Big Wigs but what is the
German government doing to reverse this
situation there's a lot of diagnosis but
who will dare to take the first step
well pay attention because in Berlin it
seems that there are more doubts than
certainties about how to face this
[Applause]
[Music]
problem an elephant in the
room for now the German authorities
diagnosis of the crime up term is to put
it mildly rather guarded first of all
law enforcement spokesmen believe that
the current statistics are difficult to
compare because of all the changes in
social habits that have taken place in
the wake of the pandemic a significant
basis for the increase in tax rates
would be the failure of the crown tax
cuts and thus the return to normal
public life more freedom of movement
also means more opportunities for
criminals the problem this seems like
nothing more than an excuse because you
see yes the return to normal C has
allowed many crimes to be perpetrated
again but that would explain the return
to 2019 levels at best however the
evolution has far exceeded that
pre-pandemic level so that does not seem
like a reasonable explanation if we
exclude the homicide rate virtually all
other crimes have grown considerably
compared to 2019 and to that we have to
add that many crimes were already in
Frank growth since 2018 so the German
government's explanation seems nothing
but a smoke screen using the pandemic to
kick forward and try to camouflage a
very negative
drift as we have seen the biggest
problem is not related to the pandemic
but to the consolidation of a lot of
criminal organizations
in Germany that could mean that crime
rates will not improve anytime soon in
other words if nothing is done the
current outbreak could be here to stay
as we saw earlier at least 100 more
organizations are operating as of 2020
than there were before the pandemic this
is what explains a 2023 marked by news
items like these Germany Italy clamped
down an Italian mob with raids arrests
Austria seizes vast weapons cache in
farri biker r
13 defendants acquitted in the Hell's
Angels trial and sentences of up to 2
years for 32 others so you see the
German security forces are facing their
biggest challenge since the
reunification of the country that said
the question is do you think these
criminal organizations in Germany are
here to stay how would you deal with
this problem leave us your impressions
in the comments and let's start a debate
and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already done so thank you for being
there all the best see you next
[Music]
time